so I have some example questions here
from Khan Academy on arc measure and
like always I encourage you to pause the
video after you see each of these
questions and try to solve them before I
do so this first question says what is
the arc measure in degrees of Arc AC on
circle P below so this is point a that
is Point C and when they're talking
about arc AC since they only have two
letters here we can assume it's going to
be the minor arc and we talked about the
minor arc there's two potential arcs
that connect point a and Point C there's
a one here on the left and then there's
the one on there is the one on the right
and since C isn't exactly isn't exactly
straight down from a it's a little bit
to the right
the shorter arc the arc with a smaller
length or the minor arc is going to be
this one that I'm depicting here right
on the right so what is this arc measure
going to be well the measure of this arc
is going to be exactly the same thing as
in degrees as the measure of the central
angle that intercepts the arc
so that's central angle let me do it in
a different color I'll do it in this
blue color that central angle is angle C
P a angles CPA and the measure of that
central angle is going to be 70 degrees
plus 104 degrees it's going to be this
whole thing right over there
so it's going to be 174 degrees 174
degrees that's the arc measure in
degrees of Arc AC let's keep doing these
so let me do another one
so this next one asks us in the figure
below in the figure below segment ad so
this is point a this is point D so
segment ad is this one right over here
let me see if I can draw that that's a D
right over there
ad and C are diameters of the circle so
let me draw C e so C E is we're going to
connect Point C and E these are
diameters so
let me so they go straight whoops I'm
using the wrong tool let me so those are
somehow I should i alright so those are
diet whoops how did that happen so let
me somehow my pin got really big
alright that me almost there okay so see
II there you go so those are both
diameters of the circle P what is the
arc measure of a B of arc a B and
degrees so arc a B once again there's
two potential arcs that connect point a
and B there's the minor arc consist this
only has two letters we'll assume it's
the mine arc it's going to be this one
over here there's a major arc but to
denote the major arc they would have
said something like a EB or ADB or arc
ACB to make us go this kind of the this
long way around but this is arc a B so
we in order to find the arc measure we
just really have to find the measure of
the central angle this is a central
angle that intercepts that arc or you
could even say it defines that arc in
some way so how can we figure out this
angle this one's a little bit trickier
well the key to the key here is to
realize that this is 93 degree angle it
is vertical to this whole angle right
over here and we know from geometry
which we're still learning as we do this
example problem that vertical angles are
going to have the same measure so if
this one on this one is 93 degrees in
this entire blue one right over here is
also going to be let me write it this is
also going to be 93 degrees so 93
degrees that's going to be made up of
this red angle that we care about and
the 38 degrees so this red one which is
which is the measure of the central
angle it's also the arc measure of Arc a
B is going to be 93 minus 93 degrees
minus 38 degrees so what is that going
to be let's say 93 I can write degrees
there - 38 degrees that is going to be
equal to C if it was 93 minus 40
it would be it would be 53 it's going to
be two more it's going to be 55 degrees
55 degrees and we are done this angle
right over here is 55 degrees if you
were to add this angle measure plus 38
degrees you'd get 93 degrees and that
has the same measure because it's
vertical with this angle right over here
with angle D P e alright let's do one
more of these so we have in the figure
below and it doesn't quite fit on the
page but we'll scroll down in a second a
B is the diameter of circle P is the
diameter of circle P all right so a B is
a diameter let me label that so a B is a
diameter so going straight across
straight across the circle what is the
arc measure of a B C in degrees so a B C
so they're making us go the long way
around this is a major arc they're
talking about let me draw it arc a what
is the arc measure of Arc ABC so we're
going the long way around so it's a
major arc so what is that going to be
well it's going to be in degrees the
same measure as the angle as the central
angle that intercepts it so it's going
to be the same thing as this central
angle right over here well what is that
central angle going to be well since we
know that this is a diameter since a B
is a diameter we know we know that this
part of it this part of it is going to
be 180 degrees we're going halfway
around the circle 180 degrees and so if
we want to look at this whole angle the
angle that intercepts the major arc ABC
it's going to be the 180 degrees plus 69
degrees so we're going to have 180
degrees plus 69 degrees which is equal
to what is that 249 249 degrees that's
the arc measure of this major arc
ABC